you guys want how what does this mean to
you guys
i think this means a lot just not for us
because we want for our country not for
us personally it wasn't an
individualistic mission it was a
like a cultural mission we're here for
our love along for our country who's
been suffering for years
and now we are so happy that at this
moment lebanon is feeling joy and pride
again
what was your highlight for the season
winning
and knowing that we will be able to um
give a lot more in vegas because we will
be given the material to end the chance
too this is so exciting for us what are
you guys gonna do with the prize money
whatever i say yeah it will be split
between all of the girls of course but
mainly it will be invested in our art in
a studio for us to be able to to train
and do what we do best amazing how is it
core gardening these beautiful girls
it's what i love to do i never feel like
i'm working i was born to do this
so if i don't i'll be treating myself
bad so
yes anyway guys congratulations have a
great night tonight